في الساعه الماضيه اشرت الى استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي على عده احياء في غزه وكذلك
هناك كما تبعنا قصف لمنزل في رفح جنوبي
القطاع اسفر عن شهداء واصابات ماذا لديك
من
معلومات صحيح القصف الاسرائيلي على مدينه
غزه متواصل ما بين فينه واخرى الا ان في
هذه الساعات الاخيره حده القصف على مدينه
غزه هي اقل من الايام الماضيه علما ان هذه
المنطقه تاوي عشرات الاف النازحين لكن
يتركز القصف الاسرائيل المدفعي في محيط
البلده القديمه ومحيط مستشفى المعمداني
والمناطق الشرقيه التي تتواجد بها قوات
الاحتلال لكن في هذا المشهد اليوم وهو
المشهد الصعب الانساني الذي هو داخل مجمع
الشفاء الطبي بعد ان فقدت المواطنون كافه
مصادر التدفئه مع دخول الجو الذي هو اشد ق
سساوى من هذا القصف ونحن على مشارف
الاربعينيه وهي الاشد بردا في الطقس
الفلسطيني الان الكثير من العائلات تشعل
النيران في داخل اروقه مستشفى الشفاء على
الرغم من قله الموارد وقله الاخشاب وقله
المصادر التي يحصل عليها المواطنون لاشعال
هذه النيران الان هذه
العائلات تعمل على تدفئه الاطراف ونفسها
بعد ان تاوت في داخل هذه الخيام في داخل
الساحات بعد ان اكتظت اروقه مستشفى الشفاء
بالنازحين
الان ال ايضا في هذا المكان عدد من
الافراد وعدد من النازحين يفترشون الارض
للنوم بعد ان رحلوا و نزحوا من بيوتهم
التي هي تقطن في المناطق الشرقيه او حتى
في المناطق الغربيه كل هذه المشاهد تتكرر
ما بين ازقه مستشفى الشفاء او اروقه
مستشفى الشفاء حتى الجرحى في داخل مستشفى
الشفاء الان هم على جزء منهم مفترش الارض
هم بلا اغطيه في الاجواء البارده يلتحفون
السماء يعني هذا هذه الاجواء لا يكفي بها
غطاء واحد لكن يتشارك في نفس الغطاء
الكثير من افراد العائله الكثير من
الاصدقاء الكثير من الافراد الان الطقس
شديد شديد البروده كثير من العائلات الان
هي تشعل النيران في مختلف اروقه مستشفى
الشفاء هذا المشهد هو جزء بسيط مما تعانيه
العائلات الفلسطينيه لكن يبقى المشهد
الصعب الكثير من النازحين في هذا المكان
هم بلا غطاء وبلا ماوى وحتى بلا مكان
يتسترون منه في حال تساقطت الامطار
الامطار على مجمع الشفاء الطبي